[Aplausos]
[Música]
efectivamente ya decía la presentadora
trabajo en esta universidad al principio
trabajé como profesor de filosofía ética
filosofía latinoamericana en total han
sido unos 15 años y luego como rector y
en toda esta experiencia en estos años
yo he llegado a una convicción de
llegado a varias pero la que yo quiero
exponer ahora es la siguiente
la fe había influido por la felicidad
iba a decir la felicidad pero no es tan
feliz lo que voy a decir la educación no
es la clave para el desarrollo
[Música]
no es la clave la educación no es la
puerta no es el camino no es el pilar
del desarrollo
esto se escucha por todos los medios las
reinas de belleza lo dicen los ministros
de estado lo dicen hasta los premios
nobel dicen lo mismo que la educación es
la clave del desarrollo pero cuando todo
el mundo
personajes grandes personajes que no
tienen educación cuando todo el mundo
coincide y repite una y otra vez lo
mismo
[Música]
tenemos que estamos frente a lo que se
llama un lugar común o sea cuando todo
el mundo repite sin cuestionar estamos
creando un mito de esos mitos urbanos
nadie cuestiona todo el mundo cree pero
nadie piensa y efectivamente decimos sin
mucho pensar sin mucha sin mucho
procesamiento que la educación es la
clave para el desarrollo
ahora cuál es el problema con esto el
problema obviamente no es que es bueno
llenarse de conocimientos aprender
transformarse eso está bien el problema
es que la educación como tal es una
herramienta y como una herramienta
cualquiera se la puede utilizar bien o
se la puede utilizar mal y de hecho en
la sociedad la educación está haciendo
mal utilizada porque está mal
distribuida la educación está llegando
solamente lo sea la buena educación que
es la que cuenta está llegando solamente
a aquellos a quienes les interesa
mantener las cosas tal como está a
quienes les podría beneficiar un cambio
del status quo no les está llegando la
buena educación
no les está llegando
hay solución a esto si hay solución
claro que hay solución
pongo aquí estás y también de este
pedagogo guatemalteco la educación no es
la clave para el desarrollo más bien el
desarrollo es la clave para la educación
invirtamos los términos y veamos qué se
puede hacer para que realmente la
educación funcione como nosotros creemos
que debería funcionar como una
herramienta que cambia la sociedad
cambiando a las personas
hace falta construir condiciones
que el desarrollo social político
económico potencia la educación en otras
palabras hay que saber aprender hay que
trabajar para que la educación se
distribuya adecuadamente la educación se
distribuya y llegue a aquellos
que no tienen acceso a una buena
educación y sin embargo necesitan que la
educación que hay mucha gente con
capacidades pero no a todos ellos les
llegan las mismas oportunidades
voy a hablar un poquito me voy a centrar
más en algo que algo conozco por mis
años de trabajo que es la educación
superior el mundo de las universidades
de escuelas politécnicas
en fin formación que como decimos en la
universidad es de calidad
somos en la universidad algo complicados
nos gustan palabras difíciles decimos la
calidad académica la calidad educativa
que sucede quien la gran mayoría de las
universidades o mejor dicho todas las
universidades queremos ser universidades
de calidad y en eso estamos de acuerdo
hay tal vez ahí hay otro mito porque es
quien va a cuestionar la calidad quién
va a decir que la calidad no está bien
todos queremos de universidades de
calidad todos queremos de entrar a
universidades de calidad en las
universidades queremos tener estudiantes
de calidad profesores de calidad porque
así nos convertimos en instituciones
parecidas
el problema con esto es que la calidad
se está entendiendo como un estado algo
que tú tienes o que no tienes la calidad
es una especie de fotografía en este
momento tú eres de calidad pasaste el
examen
entras a la universidad
falla algo se toma la foto no eres de
calidad no entras a la universidad y
esto que produce esto produce una idea
de calidad selectiva y algo que es
selectivo por un lado por el otro lado
es
de modo que tenemos en el mundo
universidades elitistas finalmente que
se consideran de calidad porque atraen a
los que ellos llaman los mejores y
terminan excluyendo a muchas personas
son universidades que se sienten
orgullosas por el número de personas que
excluyen nunca lo van a decir así nunca
lo van a decir así y sin embargo existe
para ellas la calidad es sinónimo de
elitismo
frente a esto obviamente hay reacciones
yo creo que podemos simplificar las en 2
para algunos esto es chocante y dicen no
a esta calidad excluyente elitista yo
coincido en parte pero no totalmente
para otros con los cuales no coincido
para nada
dicen esos otros dicen sí claro sí al
club de los mejores si al club de los
pocos y yo quiero pertenecer a ese club
de los pocos porque yo me considero de
los mejores
claro esto es siempre y cuando
consideramos la calidad como un estado
que en un momento determinado tienes o
no tienes yo creo sin embargo que es
posible entender concebir otro modo de
calidad educativa y esto que digo para
la universidad puede valer también para
los colegios hay otro modo de concebir
la calidad educativa que no se parece a
la foto del instante
se la puede entender no como un estado
estable diríamos estático tres veces
para decir lo mismo estado estable
estático sino como un proceso como una
dinámica un movimiento
en el siglo 16 no había ni fotos no
había películas y sin embargo en aquella
época los jesuitas
descubrieron o dieron cuerpo a una
palabra mágica entonces y sepan quiénes
son los jesuitas
yo sí sé más o menos si esta experiencia
y muchos de ustedes saben es una orden
religiosa de la compañía de jesús nació
en el siglo 16 pero bueno descubrieron
una palabra mágica
magis maris
qué significa machismo es un adverbio
del latín crítica más que
o más te pero no más que el vecino no
más que el prójimo sino más de uno mismo
ser más uno mismo sin dejar de ser uno
mismo
allá en el siglo pasado en el 16 prevén
ciclo pasado cuando yo tenía unos 18 o
19 años yo estudiaba en la escuela
politécnica nacional aquí al lado
entonces si hay aquí alguno de la
politécnica aquí hay un estudiante de la
politécnica otro por ahí en fin yo
estaba contento de estudiar ingeniería
electrónica me gustaba armar y desarmar
las cosas más las desarmada y era más
difícil armar las de nueva pero igual
estaba contenta
pero quiso un poquito ir más allá y me
vine a la católica a estudiar francés y
estando aquí hice algo más
y entonces viene una conferencia
sobre marxismo y cristianismo que
relaciones podía haber entre sus dos
mundos de pensamiento y después de eso
no estuve satisfecho y busque algo más y
entré a un grupo juvenil un grupo
juvenil de la época aquí tenemos una
amiga que estuve en ese grupo
y me gustó pero quise probar más cosas
entonces me cambié a la universidad
católica a esta universidad para
estudiar filosofía
estudié filosofía
me gustó pero luego no algo más vamos a
buscar más
entonces entré en relación con las
comunidades cristianas de chimborazo
donde estaba monseñor leonidas proaño no
sé si han escuchado hablar de leonidas
proaño los llamaban el obispo rojo
simplemente porque se preocupaba de los
campesinos y eso me atrajo dije tengo
que ir a ver fui
y en ese proceso conocí a un jesuita que
me invitó a un retiro espiritual y que
me ayudó a entender que ese movimiento
interior que yo tenía esa dinámica
interior de estar insatisfecho en un
nivel superior insatisfecho ahí e ir a
otro nivel superior insatisfecho e ir
más allá que esa dinámica interior
coincidía con esta palabra mágica en el
match es el buscar siempre algo más de
uno mismo
y yo creo que de aquí se puede sacar
este segundo concepto de calidad que yo
digo se opone o se distingue del
concepto estático de calidad
la calidad ya hablando en el campo
educativo como un proceso que lleva al
estudiante a su máximo nivel de
capacidad
la calidad como un despliegue de la
persona hacia niveles más altos de ser y
de poder a esto le llamamos del ser más
y repito no ser más que el vecino no
tener más ni siquiera eso no entra en
consideración ser más uno mismo
desplegarse uno mismo mover esos
resortes internos y no tiene para hacer
más
de todo el concepto de calidad inspirado
en el maíz esto es del 50% todavía falta
la otra mitad y la otra mitad está en
ser más con una finalidad ser más con un
propósito
como decimos en esta universidad y en
otras universidades ser más para servir
mejor
y aquí entramos a hablar de otro ámbito
entramos y damos otro terreno no
solamente de la calidad académica nos
salimos de la universidad y pisamos el
terreno de la excelencia humana de la
calidad humana que se puede resumir al
menos para los que estamos en este
ambiente de pensamiento en el ser más
para servir mejor ser más para servir
mejor no solamente ser más y punto ser
más con un propósito
de aquí entonces que podríamos hablar
grosso modo de dos tipos de universidad
lo mismo podría decirse también de los
colegios y de las escuelas incluso de
las mentalidades dos tipos de
universidad tenemos por un lado esa
universidad selectiva y excluyente que
se enorgullece del número de personas
que excluyen y tenemos por el otro lado
una universidad incluyente y que
transforma
que pone atención
en la calidad como un proceso de
despliegue de las capacidades de las
personas
ustedes dirán van estos son ideas puras
ideas
son ideas claro pero basadas en hechos y
hay experiencias una de las
universidades más como diría yo más
innovadoras de eeuu
hoy es arizona state university no sé si
han escuchado hablar
y ya lleva un poco más de una década
trabajando en esta idea de combinar
innovación educativa calidad educativa e
inclusión y está funcionando
e incluso el rector creo que dejó de ser
rector michael crow ha sido nombrado
hace unas dos semanas no más de dos
semanas una de las 50 personas más
influyentes por la revista forbes
y en ecuador también tenemos qué
los mejores bachilleres no provienen
necesariamente de los colegios de la
capital
en fin dos tipos de universidad una que
pone el centro en la universidad en la
calidad como un estado que toma la foto
y entras o no entras u otra que entiende
la calidad como un proceso de despliegue
de la persona queridos jóvenes a los que
están aquí a los que se sienten jóvenes
si podemos hacer que la educación
transforme la sociedad si podemos hacer
que la educación cambie en la medida en
que podamos hacer que la educación de
calidad llegue a todos que las
oportunidades también lleguen a todos
los que tienen capacidades y a todos los
que son autoridades no pueden llegar a
ser autoridades muchos de ustedes
también les digo pensemos en cambiar el
tipo de universidad que tenemos y
también pensemos en cambiar el tipo de
colegios que tenemos hacia una
universidad colegio institución
educativa que entienda la calidad como
un proceso y no como un estado y que en
esa medida incluya a más personas
para que la educación cambie comencemos
por cambiar la educación para que la
educación cambie la sociedad
comencemos por cambiar la educación
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]